honestly you're out of ideas just play
Rab Lux it's obvious
boots hasn't tried roblox he or should
play roblox oops that's what I call a
good game my roblox fears it's the game
you're looking for clip i play roblox
play roblox play roblox play roblox
roblox boy play roblox you forgot roblox
you piece of crappy note no I swore
never never I will played that game
never in a million goddamn yes
if you play roblox I will donate you
$100 well why didn't you [ __ ] say so
hell yeah we're playing we're playing
bro we're playing roblox everyone you
could have started with that comment
let's begin our journey to roblox autism
simulator 2017 I might not make it out
of life my levels are still pretty high
I could be overdosing I asked you guys
on Twitter which ones I should play
fidget spinners adopt a cute family
upgrading roblox but how can you upgrade
what is already perfection does that is
that [ __ ] wearing a Chanel
t-shirt well doing a fidget spinner hell
yeah hell yeah this is my game choose
your job well they don't have youtubers
so I'm gonna have to go with the the
second closest one Wow incredible
[Laughter]
excuse me excuse me can I get some help
well I'm back I'm back
whoa she's got a fidget spinner oh my
god whoa she's showing it off to me
can you fidget my spinner oh come on oh
my god the screen is so [ __ ]
cluttered then I just kill her over my
lap with my fidget spinner with great
power comes great fidgets penis hell
yeah
this really seems like a really good
game oh wow
justice good old Sunday Drive well this
is my car now stop in the name of the
law what Jesus Christ I think my car
became a fidget spinner oh my god I just
killed a police officer
but I'm just a fellow McDonald's worker
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
thoughts get killed
all right well that's cool I think it's
time to move on
counter blocks roblox Offensive what
what whoa holy [ __ ] this is just like
battlefield two
oh my god is just like battlefield what
the [ __ ] god them that's pretty [ __ ]
cool actually do not play warning scary
apparently the game modes are YouTube
clickbait titles Wow incredible
[Music]
hi the [ __ ] sister I can't do
anything
shut up just shut up oh [ __ ] I'm so
scared guys I'm so [ __ ] scared you
know god I hope nothing comes out and
kills me
oh my god I'm [ __ ] myself by the
walls got me I'm fine I'm fine oh
nothing is that what is that is that an
ak-47 I'm saved
slender it's about to get a taste of his
own medicine I'm joined by my army of
bullets
just stay still I got him I'll get him
for you
oh my the bullets don't work they don't
work oh my god fidget spinners robloxian
high school hey everyone it's PewDiePie
here with my fidget spinner dananananana
den in it and in it denna nanana nanan
and sowest say what's the prob this has
to be the saddest point in my life this
is actually more sad when I was in high
school I managed to top myself I'm
sitting alone in a cafeteria in roblox
with a goddamned fidget spanner and
there's no one here
[Music]
best game evar 10 out of 10 so no yes
that's a hot cheerleader girl what's up
oh she's looking at my fidget spinner
she just jumped over it well it's still
just like high school
oh hello baby oh hello baby where are
you going hey I'm stuck I'm [ __ ]
stuck my [ __ ] God hi what are you come
back baby you want to fidget my spinner
stop jumping over at your [ __ ] come
back here you will
fidget my spinner [ __ ] or you can play
as Vietnam in roblox hell yeah this is
how the pros play
[Music]
[Laughter]
what up dog what up [ __ ]
surprise [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
well I'm back playing my favorite server
or you can abduct little kids one moment
I just need to figure some things out I
think my arm is broken and shoulder is
dis okay we're flying now okay here we
go
[Music]
get in how do I drown him [ __ ] I'm
drowning no funny time for a rap battle
knuckle oh I'm not gonna lie this game
makes me want makes me cry but so just
your mom
when I when I come in her eye what the
[ __ ] are you saying Rick you're blue
like a fish
oh Sh oh [ __ ] I make you dish and put
you on my wife playing roblox is gay
which is okay just kidding
roblox is gay drops mic [ __ ] I had more
I had more in me what the [ __ ] is this
piece of [ __ ] game are you [ __ ]
kidding me
roblox isn't gay oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
she voted me out because off you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh it's like slim area great
get [ __ ] [ __ ] get [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone gets [ __ ] get [ __ ]
roblox ro Club shooting fire get [ __ ]
I dropped some new merch it's selling
like a dog charges every day bro it's
every day bro [ __ ] christ